[Music]
foreign
we call it the hooch I would get these
like large gallons through the laundry
room so we had like the detergent that
would finish I would stash all those
bottles families in New York state you
could bring like packages up to your
loved ones once a month so I would ask
them to send me like grapes grapefruit
and just rot all the fruit and these
bottles and then I'll take like 10
Kool-Aid all the stuff and then I'll
steal like the coffee filters from the
staff that was working in the library so
I'll take those coffee filters take
bread and that'll be my yeast and I'll
mold the bread all together and I'll
stick it into the coffee filter wrap it
up and then I'm sticking it in the
bottle and so it'll ferment and so
you'll take that bottle and you'll open
it up little by little to gas it out
because if you don't gas it out it'll
just blow up like a volcano and I've had
that happen before and it's not pretty
and it stinks your toilet is your
refrigerator because it's like a metal
toilet you can make it in eight days and
it'll taste like wine